CORNELIUS WILLIS: Hi.
I'm Cornelius Willis with the
Google Cloud Platform team.
And I'm so excited
today because we
get to talk to two eminent
technologists at Google.
First, we have Andrew Fikes,
who is a distinguished software
engineer at Google, who is
working on Bigtable and also
the Spanner project, which we
published some papers about.
And then Amin Vahdat, who is
Google Fellow and the Technical
Lead for Networking.
And we brought these
two folks together
because the relationship
between the services we provide
on Google Cloud Platform and the
capabilities of the underlying
infrastructure are really
what define Google Cloud
Platform as a whole.
You can't really look
at any of these things
separately and understand
really how they come together
and provide something
truly extraordinary.
Some questions.
So Amin, you've said in
public talks computing
is at a crossroads
and networking
is going to define what
computing is in the future.
So why is that?
AMIN VAHDAT: That's
a great question.
I think it really
is an exciting time
to be thinking about
the future of computing.
We've been to some extent
spoiled in computer science
for many, many
decades, where we would
get basically free performance
improvements every 18
months or so.
If you wanted your software to
run faster, all you had to do
was wait for the latest greatest
processors to become available,
upgrade your hardware, and
magically your software
runs faster.
For the last few years,
this has changed,
as we've now not
been able to make
individual processors
faster, but we've
delivered more of them.
So the programming model
has had the change.
And the network is
really the key enabler
for bringing more and
more servers together
to work on bigger
and bigger problems.
So in other words, if I look
at what we do at Google,
we're bringing together
hundreds, oftentimes thousands,
of servers together on
individual computations.
And it is the
network that allows
us to treat these hundreds
or thousands of servers
as one unit of computation.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
I've heard you say
that it's important
to have balance
between the different parts
of the infrastructure,
and you have to
feed the processors.
If you have all that
processing capacity,
you have to make
sure that there's
the network connectivity to
give them data to work on.
AMIN VAHDAT: That's right,
and so one way to look at this
is that servers need
data to compute on.
Just doing computation
without any data
is not very interesting.
And at Google, and I think
at virtually anyplace that's
interesting, the data is
not local to a server.
There's no way that you're
going to have the data that you
need local to you.
So any data that you're
going to compute on
is living across the
network somewhere.
And that's why it's so
great to be working closely
with folks like Andrew,
because the networking is
about storage, and I think
storage works very closely
with networking.
So if you look at
a processor that
can do billions and billions
of operations every second,
how do you make
sure that you feed
it data to keep going
at that rate, otherwise
it's stalled waiting
for the data.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So
build our own networking
gear and our own
networking software.
Why did we start doing that?
AMIN VAHDAT: A
very simple answer.
We couldn't buy for any price
the scale and performance
network that we needed
to feed our processors.
In other words, we had
particular applications
that we needed to run,
starting with web search,
but continuing across
many different kinds
of applications, like
today on Google Cloud.
We couldn't buy a network that
would provide the capabilities
that we needed.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: All right.
Got it.
So you're the Google Lead
for Storage Services--
ANDREW FIKES: Mm-hmm.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: --how has
your design and the services
you provide different because
of what we have in our network?
ANDREW FIKES: Well, building
a global storage service
is, first off,
hard in some ways.
And what Amin and the networking
team brings to the table
is they really take one of those
really difficult problems off
of my deck of things
that I have to deal with.
So oftentimes we're dealing
with extremely large
datasets-- many,
many petabytes--
and as Amin mentioned, we're
bringing that data together
to sort of answer
questions and compute over.
And being able to take the
network out of the equation,
because I can depend
on it to be there,
I can depend on it
to be really low
latency, means that I
can make a lot of really
interesting system
design choices.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So it
means that you're not
spending so much time making
sure the network is delivering
bandwidth.
You just assume it's there, and
you can design your services
for very, very low latency.
Just make that assumption.
ANDREW FIKES: You can
make that assumption,
and it also opens up a whole
set of interesting things
that you can do.
Amin talked about
how we don't think
about storage as being local.
That means I can move compute
from one node to another
very quickly and access it
with the same latencies.
And this lets us work
around hotspots in the data
or machines going down.
It allows us to recover
things much faster.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: Good.
So how is our-- I know
this is a huge question,
and I'm asking you to
answer it ad hoc like this,
but how is our approach to
networking different from
everybody else's?
AMIN VAHDAT: Yeah.
That's a great question,
a hard question.
I think it started
with scale and speed.
That was the simple part
maybe 10, 12 years ago.
But where we're at
right now is also
availability and what we
call internal tail latency.
So in other words, when we're
doing distributive computation,
you don't just care about how
fast you can get at the data
most of the time-- excuse
me, in the average case.
You care about how fast
you can get at the data
at the tail end of
the distribution
or the 99th percentile.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
So the worst case.
AMIN VAHDAT: The worst case.
Exactly.
So we design for availability,
we design for security,
and we design for
predictability,
making sure that
the worst case is
very close to the average case.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: Got it.
So a very narrow bell curve.
A very narrow
distribution curve.
ANDREW FIKES: And that actually
becomes relatively important.
If you take a computation which
starts and goes to one server
and then collects data from
1,000 different servers,
the probability that you find
that sort of tail latency
and it impacting
your computation
happens all the time.
So you have to really
plan for that worst case.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So in
distributed operation,
you send it out to
many, many servers.
It comes back and
the last one in--
ANDREW FIKES: Yes.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: --is the
one that actually determines
what the performance is.
ANDREW FIKES: We have
to wait on all the data
to come back in order to
deliver a correct answer.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: The design
that I've heard you talk about
in some of your talks is that
you used all this commodity
gear and then centrally
control it and use
sort of centralized
algorithms to determine
what the actual connectivity
of the network is.
And so that's really different
from the way most people do it,
right?
AMIN VAHDAT: That's right.
What's beautiful
about networking,
as traditionally defined, is
that no one knows their role
in the network.
Everyone sort of
self-discovers where they are.
That's sort of the
basis for the internet.
One of the things that we saw
at Google though, is that we're
building these
data centers, we're
building these data
center networks,
and how we connect
all the servers
together is pre-determined.
In other words, the roles
and responsibilities
of every switching element
is known at design time.
It's not something that has
to be discovered or learned
over time, as is the case
with the traditional internet.
So at Google, again,
without really knowing it,
we tripped upon the notion of
software-defined networking.
Having a--
CORNELIUS WILLIS: And
when was this, by the way?
AMIN VAHDAT: This was about
10 years ago when I started.
Now, software-defined networking
has very specific meanings now,
and it talks about particular
ways of doing things,
but the spirit in
the end is that you
have a logically centralized
control over a very large scale
fabric.
And that's what
we've wound up at.
And, frankly, we borrowed these
ideas from storage systems
at Google.
We always thought in
terms of-- of course,
Andrew can say much
more about this,
but a storage infrastructure
consisting of tens of thousands
of disks is
centrally controlled.
So it was natural
for us to think
the same way for how
the network was going
to be planned and controlled.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: But in the
argument that I've heard,
and I don't know if
it's a [INAUDIBLE]
or not but that having
that central control
also creates a liability,
hence vulnerability.
AMIN VAHDAT: It certainly can.
But what we've found
is that it actually
makes the system simpler in
the end compared to a fully
decentralized scheme.
You do have the
potential liability
of a centralized
controller, and that's
why I use the fudge word
logically centralized.
We don't literally have
a single point control.
It's just that we have
relatively sophisticated
algorithms based on
systems like Chubby
that we've published about in
the past, paxos-based leader
election, that would make it
easy for us to build logically
centralized control.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So Google is
running its own private network
connecting all of
its data centers
and all of its services.
And if you're a Google
Cloud Platform customer,
you're on the private network.
So is it different for
you writing services
with the understanding that
that's a private network
rather than being connected
over the public internet?
ANDREW FIKES: Yes.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
How is it different?
ANDREW FIKES: I think in many
ways we're fairly spoiled.
We have a really strong team
of operations people that
are monitoring this network.
It is the same
network that carries
our user facing traffic
of Search, Gmail,
and other things.
And so it is a resource that
incredibly precious to us.
We spend a lot of
time making sure
that the capacity
planning is done well
and that it performs as
sort of as the specs say.
AMIN VAHDAT: The bandwidth
between our data centers
is a real enabler for us.
And, frankly, we have more
bandwidth between our data
centers than many companies have
inside of their data centers.
And that really
breaks down distance,
where you can think of data
that is across the data center
as being almost local.
But, frankly, we
can also even think
of data that's stored
in a different data
center as something
that we can go
get as part of our
computation in many cases.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So I've heard
customers talk about this idea
that they may be
wherever there app is,
wherever their customer
is in the world,
it's just like the
customer is right there
from a latency and a performance
and customer experience
perspective.
It doesn't really matter
where they're running.
ANDREW FIKES: That's right.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
So I understand
one of the statistics that
has been thrown around
is that we have bisectional
bandwidth between any two
points in our network of
1 petabyte per second.
And I also know that the
total aggregate bandwidth
of the entire internet right
now is some fraction of that,
like 2 terabytes per second
or something like that.
AMIN VAHDAT: 200 terabytes or
so of the bisection bandwidth,
roughly.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So
what's the right way
to think about
those two systems?
It's kind of crazy that
Google has more bandwidth
in its network than the
entire internet does.
AMIN VAHDAT: Well, so
this is the distinction
between local area networks
and the wide area network.
So one of our data
center buildings
will go scale to about
a petabyte per second.
And that allows all the
servers within that building
in aggregate to talk
to one another at just
enormous [INAUDIBLE] rates.
So the way to look
at this is that you
can transfer vast, vast, vast
amounts of data among all
the servers to one another.
What is this driven by?
It's the fact that computers
can talk to each other
much faster than people
can talk to the network.
In other words, what drives
wide area network communication
across the internet?
It's people doing web searches,
people consuming videos.
The amount of bandwidth
required for that
in the grand scheme
of things is tiny
compared to what the servers
within the data center
need to do to provide all
that information to end users.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: Good.
So when I type in a big
query to a 3 terabyte table,
and it comes back
in a few seconds,
it's because of that bandwidth
within that data center.
AMIN VAHDAT: There's
thousands of servers
that are storing that
data, and if there one
we wouldn't be able to fit
that data on any one server,
but even if we
could, we'd run out
of computation power
on that server.
We have to distribute it across
thousands of servers for it
to work.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
So I understand
we brought a switch
from our data center.
Can we go take a look at it?
AMIN VAHDAT: Yeah, sure.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: Wow,
this thing is enormous.
What is this?
AMIN VAHDAT: This is one small
piece of a Jupiter network.
This is what powers all the
connectivity in our data center
networks.
It is called a super
rack, affectionately
within the group,
and it is one stage
in a multi-stage
topology that connects
all our servers together.
So this is the middle stage.
This connects all the
server racks to one another
below it at the first stage.
And above it is yet
another stage of networking
that looks somewhat like this.
Basically data packets
flow from the servers
up through the super
rack and then back down
to other servers
across the network.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So
what's different here
from what I might see
in another data center
that some of our listeners may
have experienced in their data
centers?
AMIN VAHDAT: So when
you buy commercial gear,
you usually buy a
single switch, and it
might look a lot more glossy.
It' might have a lot
more shine on it.
It might not have all
of the cables that
are interconnecting things.
Basically what
we're doing is we're
exposing the fact that
any big switch is composed
of a lot of small ones.
So if you were to zoom in
here what you would notice
is that right over here
is actually one switch.
It's about 7 inches tall,
and there are eight of them
in this column,
another eight in here.
So a total of 16 switches
in this super rack.
Each one of these switches
is a commodity switch.
So the things that
anyone might buy
is a standard top of rack
switch on the commodity,
and they're driven by volume.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
And so I notice
that we got yellow fiberoptic
cables here but also a lot
of conventional copper as well.
AMIN VAHDAT: That's right.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So how
do those work together?
What's the reason we have that?
AMIN VAHDAT: So we
have some black cables.
These are the copper cables.
And again, in
traditional networks,
which is what you would
have, is a copper backplane.
It would be hidden.
It would be in the back.
It would have copper traces
etched on a piece of metal.
And that would
provide connectivity
among all of the individual
switching elements.
Here we've chosen to expose that
by using commodities switches.
Again, commodity switches
don't have the big backplane.
So we actually provide
connectivity from every switch
to every other switch
within the super rack.
And those are the
black copper cables.
Copper cables have
a limited reach,
about the reach of
this super rack here.
If you want to leave the
super rack, distances
beyond a few meters, you
need to go fiber optics.
So these yellow
interconnects are
the interconnects that leave
the super rack, either going
to the higher stage of
the switching topology
or down to the server racks.
So for example, the
server racks would
have also the other
end of the yellow fiber
optic cables that connect
to the copper rack switch.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So
how is this different
from earlier generations?
AMIN VAHDAT: We
actually went along
a number of different lines
in building our switching
infrastructure for modularity.
And the software
and the hardware
is designed for being able
to support upgrade in place
across the data center.
And that was really
a key insight
in that to be able to
maintain availability
of our infrastructure,
we had to live
with upgrading it continuously.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So the
Google Cloud Platform
that our customers are
on today is constantly
being upgraded and revised.
AMIN VAHDAT: That's right.
This is just one
generation of our switching
gear, one of many.
And what we found is that both
internally for Google products
from search to YouTube,
no one can only
tolerate taking down an entire
data center for six months
while we upgrade the
entire infrastructure.
What that means is
that all of our servers
must continuously run
while the network is
being upgraded from one
generation to the next.
And this super rack
is a modular piece.
It is interchangeable
with other super racks
such that we can be upgrading
one for another with no service
downtime.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So
this is not the be all
and end all of Good networking.
AMIN VAHDAT: Oh, far from it.
So this was designed and
deployed in about 2012.
It was the fifth generation
of in-house Google networking
gear.
You can imagine that
since 2012 we've
been working on subsequent
generations, some of which
have seen deployment
in the data center now.
And as we speak, we're designing
the next next generation
of hardware and
software that will
go into the data
center for deployment
in 2016, 2017, and 2018.
It's never ending to deliver
the latest and greatest
for Google's network.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So Andrew,
a lot of atoms in one
place here for a
software guy, right?
ANDREW FIKES: Yes, absolutely.
It's quite professional looking.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So let's go
talk more about the future.
So that is quite a machine.
AMIN VAHDAT: It's some switch.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
So what is what
we're doing there is
unorthodox or controversial?
How have some of the designs
we've put out there influenced
the industry?
AMIN VAHDAT: Well, that's a
very interesting question.
I think when we
started down this path,
many people thought that
it just couldn't work.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
Commodity switches.
AMIN VAHDAT: Commodity
switches, delivering
the right levels of
availability, the right levels
of performance.
But we thought it inevitable.
In other words, if you look
at the history of computing
and the history of storage,
it's followed similar trends.
Network has just gone down
that path most recently.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: Got it.
So how are apps going to
change and programming
models going to change?
What does this mean further
up the stack for people
that are creating software?
ANDREW FIKES: Yeah.
So I mentioned earlier
sort of as a programmer,
as a system developer, being
able to depend on the network
to get access to my data.
And I think what we've
seen historically
is steps to sort of disaggregate
compute from data itself.
So this started with creating
disks that were remote
from where our servers were.
We've been looking
at disaggregating
other types of storage
recently, be it flash
or upcoming in [INAUDIBLE].
And so what I think
you'll see going forward
is much more of this
programming model
changes around being able to
ask other nodes or other pieces
of compute very quickly
over the network
to retrieve data and sort
of bring it all together.
And so from a programming
point of view,
it'll be as if your data
is local no matter where
your compute happens to be.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: Wow, so it's
taking the program wherever
the data is almost.
ANDREW FIKES: It's taking the
program wherever the data is.
It also lets us sort of
coordinate more effectively.
So when you're thinking
about large-scale distributed
computation, you have a lot
of tradeoffs you can make.
You might find that one
server is slower than another.
And you have the ability to
go out and ask people really
quickly and answer questions.
And sort of super-fast
networks that you can depend on
with low latency
frees you up to try
some of these more
interesting techniques.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So the thing
that occurs to me you as we're
talking about this is that the
same kind of disaggregation
that you're doing
in the network space
follows what we did in the
compute space as well, in that
rather than think
about the data center
as a collection of
nodes, we think about it
as one big computer.
AMIN VAHDAT: That's right.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: And
networking and storage
and even the
distributive services
that run on our
infrastructure are all
kind of designed with that
same core idea in mind.
It's the warehouse scale
computer as the paper says.
AMIN VAHDAT: Really
is the vision
that we're driving after is that
you can think of the building
as one unit of compute,
one unit of storage
and one large switch that
interconnects all of them
together.
And as Andrew was
mentioning, you
don't need to think about
where your data is stored.
It's available to you always.
It's available to you really
quickly, and in the end,
convenient programming is
being able to just reference
your data, compute
on it, generate
the next piece of data.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: When you
think about the day in the life
of the average cloud computer--
cloud developer-- today,
more than half their
time is spent just trying
to make all this stuff work.
And if you take that
out of the equation,
think about what amazing
apps people can write.
ANDREW FIKES: That's true.
We spend a lot of time
doing integration work,
so bringing pieces of
those things together.
And at Google we've
started to think a lot
about how programming models
can change to sort of work
around these
new-found latencies,
these new access-related
things, and how that actually
changes how people
develop applications.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So
what's next for your teams?
What should we expect?
AMIN VAHDAT: You know,
it's a never-ending list
of challenges.
So I think certainly on the
networking side, of course,
the networks are
going to get faster.
They're going to
get lower latency.
I think that for us, one of the
really interesting challenges
is how do we expose this all
the way to the Google Cloud
customer.
In other words, we have a
fairly specialized and powerful
programming [INAUDIBLE] that
we can deal with in networking
environments.
How do we securely and
safely expose access
to basically, if you will,
bare metal performance
all the way to the
virtualized customers.
CORNELIUS WILLIS:
Productizing inside of Google.
How about for your team, Andrew?
ANDREW FIKES: We've
been doing storage
at Google for a long time.
I'm actually very, very excited
about our cloud customer
workloads.
They bring in new
challenges for us.
And they give us an opportunity
to solve some really
interesting problems.
You know, Amin mentioned earlier
that our switches are developed
and our networks are developed
years in advance, right?
It's a continually
upgrade process.
And so from a storage
development point of view,
we're already starting to plan
for what the next networks will
bring us, what capabilities
it will actually unlock.
And so for us, we're
starting to think
about new tiers of storage
and how we integrate those
into applications and
how they can actually,
as Amin said, impact
cloud user experiences,
how we can make
development simpler,
and how we can make
reliability, availability,
and consistency of operations
around storage be better.
CORNELIUS WILLIS: So
it's exciting times.
This is the right time to
be working on Google Cloud
Platform.
Thank you both.
Thank you all for watching
today, and go out and try it.